[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story fearing and not so cordial
welcome for King Charles France
postpones his first state visit with
just two days to go
the fire and the fury on the country's
streets forced the detestable decision
says president macron warning the visit
would lack Common Sense
also tonight the victims of Yemen's
forgotten War the more than 11 million
children needing humanitarian Aid
taking the oath the Hollywood star
Gwyneth Paltrow defending herself over
claims that she was responsible for a
skiing accident
[Music]
I didn't engage in Risky Behavior I
wouldn't with my children there or
without my children there
the resident put on Facebook commenting
News and Views about how disgusting and
disgraceful this flight tip is
higher bills lower standards the warning
that despite Rising council tax key
services are continuing to fail
we really need to think rethink our
politics and our politics is in deep
on the money Brian Cox on politics
poverty and bad language as he prepares
for his final turn in the hit show
succession
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in The Press
preview from 10 30.
foreign
[Music]
as Prince of Wales Charles visited
France 34 times barter's King he's going
to have to wait a little longer for his
next trip after the country which was to
be his first destination for a state
visit asked him to postpone it follows
the chaos and protests on the streets of
Paris Bordeaux and other cities over
president macron's controversial pension
reforms he today said that it wouldn't
be serious to host his guests in the
middle of the violence well in a moment
we'll get the take from the British side
over the postponement but first our
correspondent Adele Robinson reports
from Paris
the image Paris wanted to project to a
King on his first state visit
versus reality on the streets debris and
destruction
the aftermath of some of the worst
violence seen for years across France
unrest over pension reform forced the
president to cancel the royal visit amid
condemnation on both sides over
protester attacks and police violence
with similar scenes in Bordeaux universe
this team
foreign
the King's first state visit here to
France was to be symbolic honoring
historical ties between the two
countries but macron's decision to push
three plans to raise the retirement age
to 64 without a vote has transformed the
streets of Paris into scenes of chaos a
city known for its elegance and Grandeur
and now look at this charred rubbish
broken glass and damage on the streets
of Paris it jars with the very idea of a
state visit full of Pomp and ceremony
and it would have only reinforced the
image of a leader described as
dangerously out of touch
parisians welcomed the decision to
cancel the role visit but said the
country's problems remain
yes it was a good idea to postpone the
visit because we shouldn't be showing
these dramatic views of France and in
particular Paris right now
the president under the matters he needs
to deal with at the moment the king's
visit changes nothing for us
this won't change our situation maybe he
thinks it's respectful or even that it
was a bad idea but actually he's more
concerned about the king's security than
ours
but so far no sign the unrest will stop
and nothing meaningful to help clear up
the political mess Left Behind Adele
Robinson Sky News Paris
the king's visit before his coronation
represented an important part of British
soft power one former ambassador to
France told us today Charles ham Queen
consort will now make Germany their
first official foreign destination as
our Royal correspondent Laura bundock
reports
cordial isn't foreign territory for the
king he's visited France 34 times
but this was his moment as Monarch his
first overseas State visit now on hold
with revolution in the air
I think the king will be disappointed
it's a trip that we know he was looking
forward to and that had been many months
in the planning and it was going to be a
first opportunity for us to see him as
Monarch on an overseas visit and these
visits are really important not just for
the monarchy but for the country as a
whole
the state visit was billed as a
celebration of the anglo-french
Friendship a diplomatic way of
reaffirming relations after years of
brexit fueled friction
France may be a republic but there was
huge respect for the late Queen a famed
Francophile and francophone I think the
king will have the same effect as the
queen of really triggering a sense of
affection and emotion in France when the
circumstances arrived it is a very
important part of British soft power and
that's why we need to use it in the
right circumstances
of course Safety and Security are always
the priority but this is a big blow for
Buckingham Palace just two days before
takeoff and this carefully planned
meticulously time trip has been called
off
the king and queen consort are still
visiting Germany taking in both Berlin
and Hamburg next week but no France for
now the next time the king meets macron
will be at his coronation Laura bundock
Sky News the Buckingham Palace
[Music]
the people of Yemen are in desperate
need of food Aid not enough is being
provided by the International Community
but some of that Sky News has found is
being sold rather than handed out in
Street Markets the need is clear in
Yemen one child dies every 10 minutes
from a preventable cause where years of
war have left more than 11 million
children in need of humanitarian
assistance with 2.2 million children
suffering from acute malnutrition and
more than 540 000 under the age of five
facing life-threatening severe acute
malnutrition meanwhile 2.3 million
children remain in displacement camps
with inadequate access to basic Health
Nutrition and washing facilities our
specialist correspondent Alex Crawford
reports now from Western Yemen and a
warning her report contains images of
malnourished children from the start
this is an image which should shame
she's the face of hunger in Yemen's
forgotten War
her name is Ahad and she's three years
old that weighs less than an average
newborn
she is slowly starving to death and the
medics in this remote basic Clinic can't
seem to save her
whatever food we give her her father
says she keeps throwing it up she can't
keep it down
her father's brought her in for more
checks our head also has Down syndrome
which the Medics here have rarely seen
before
the checks confirm what's painfully
obvious
Ahad is Raising red flags with every
measurement but the nearest hospital is
around 60 kilometers away and it'll cost
16 for transport Way Beyond their means
she won't be gone
and there are tens of thousands of
children like ahardin Yemen also
starving and poor
Yemen's eight-year long War has caused
Millions to flee their homes to camps
like al-jasha on the west coast it's one
of the biggest with nearly 9 000 people
all living here from hand to mouth where
everyone seems to be hungry
within seconds of arriving we were
surrounded by people begging for food
and help
we don't even have a morsel not a bit of
rice to eat he says we have nothing we
are suffocating here we are dying
the camp is a Dusty sprawling Community
where the war is never far away
and where the arrival of a new baby
means just another mouth to feed in the
midst of a conflict which has left them
homeless
there is war all around us she says it's
really scary and it's raining bullets so
how can they go home where can we go
our presence here has attracted a big
crowd from the camp they keep telling us
there's a lot of people pushing and
shoving we keep telling them we're not
an aid agency we're just journalists but
they're not listening
Yemen's enduring one of the world's
worst humanitarian disasters and these
are the people who are trying to survive
it
the Coker market nearby is packed with
people trying to find a way to eat and
we find evidence of shopkeepers selling
food Aid this is quite clearly world
food program it says on it and also not
for sale
he says it was the cheapest he could
find
yeah
he agrees to lead us to the store he
bought it from but says there are plenty
more selling food Aid
the shopkeeper seems very camera shy at
first have you got any other world food
program
um Aid here he initially denies he's got
any more food Aid he's selling in the
store
no not here he says and then tries to
hide a wfp packet in front of him
but with our camera rolling he realizes
it's a tough claim to pull off and
finally hams the food packet to me
remember this food is donated free and
meant for the most needy yeah world food
program again he's got a whole load of
those excuse out the way please look at
them all under there there's a whole
pile of them underneath the counter all
from world food program how much are you
selling these for sir he's making 700
reals or 70 cents a packet 700. do you
know this is not meant to be sold
yes he nods he knows he's not meant to
be selling donated Goods why are you
selling it then
he's worried now and says he's going to
stop selling food aid from today
but looking around his store it's packed
with sacks of rice and flour which have
also come from International donors but
he insists he's providing a service
people sell their food Aid out of
desperation he says for example if
someone wants to buy medicine they sell
the aid to me so they can afford the
medicine it's in an emergency
but the small baby clinic in Kroger run
mostly by volunteers is packed with
babies and mothers who urgently need
food they cannot afford
seven-month-old Sarah is the youngest of
seven all of them are hungry but the
baby is suffering most the doctor fears
the worst if she isn't taken to hospital
there'll be complications if she doesn't
go he says and if there are
complications she'll die for sure
the doctors say Sarah needs urgent help
but her mother can't afford the fare to
the hospital so won't go
urgent doesn't come in reals or dollars
and Fatima has six other children to
feed these are choices no mother wants
to make
Sarah's fate now seems horribly sealed
she's another young victim in Yemen's
man-made humanitarian catastrophe Alex
Crawford Sky News Yemen
our special correspondent on the ongoing
war in Yemen
now the Hollywood star Gwyneth Paltrow
has been telling a court a skier who
claims that she crashed into him leaving
him concussed down with broken ribs
actually crashed into her she said she
hadn't engaged in Risky Behavior Skies
U.S correspondent Martha Kellner reports
you may call your next witness
it's been a seven-year legal battle now
it was time for Gwyneth Paltrow's day in
court do you swear that the testimony
you are about to give in the case now
before the court will be the truth the
whole truth and nothing but the truth
shall help you God thank you
she was called unusually by the lawyers
representing a man who says her Reckless
scheme left him with a life-altering
brain injury did you know the rules at
the time of the Collision that if you're
in a collision with someone you need to
give your name and information contact
information
because I was hit by Mr Sanderson and he
was at fault I assumed that Eric who was
our ski instructor who was there at the
time who was overseeing the event he
said I'm going to leave all of your
information and he said you should go
ski down because my kids were waiting
for me Terry Sanderson a retired
optometrist listened in court he has a
very different version of events he says
Paltrow who was on a family ski holiday
plowed into him from behind in his words
like Godzilla he sustained four broken
ribs and concussion I was skiing and two
skis came between my skis forcing my
legs apart and then there was a body
pressing against me and there was a very
strange grunting noise so my brain was
trying to make sense of what was
happening I thought
am I is this a practical joke
sanderson's lawyers claimed that Academy
Award winner Gwyneth Paltrow was
distracted by her children who she was
skiing with my daughter was down the
hill my son was to my left so I was
skiing and my eyes were not fixated only
on my son when Mr Sanderson skied
directly into my back Paltrow will
continue to testify on Monday her
husband Brad falchuk and children apple
and Moses are also listed as Witnesses
the trial continues
well as you can see lawyers there having
a conversation with the judge there have
been a number of pauses in Gwyneth
Paltrow's evidence and Gwyneth Paltrow
Martha has been questioned about the
case against her
yeah she certainly has just to say first
of all there have been legal wranglings
throughout Gwyneth Paltrow's testimony
about what and what isn't admissible and
that's because this is a jury trial so
it points the jury have been told to
wipe certain parts of testimony
um from their memory but certainly it's
been an assured performance from Gwyneth
Paltrow she's obviously no stranger to
the spotlight that this is a very
different scenario and she and Terry
Sanderson the plaintiff in this case
have very different versions of events
she says that Terry Sanderson skied into
her back Terry Sanderson and in fact the
only eyewitness who's emerged in this
case say that she skied into the back of
him he says in his words it was like
Godzilla came from him came from behind
and hit him and in fact an eyewitness to
the event said that he had he was face
down in the snow for minutes after this
incident as Gwyneth Paltrow skied away
we've also heard emotional testimony
from two of Terry Sanderson who said
their father had changed dramatically in
the months and years after this ski
accident they said he'd become angry and
distant a different personalized
personality than he was before but
Gwyneth Paltrow maintaining that is no
fault of hers
Martha many thanks and do scan that QR
code that you can see there if you want
to watch Gwyneth Paltrow continue to
give evidence in court
schools regulator ofsted will not stop
its inspections it said today as it
wouldn't be in the best interests of
children head teachers we spoke to
talked about the fear many feel about
the inspections for which they get
almost no warning and which can Define
their school for many years it follows
the death of Ruth Perry a head who took
her own life while waiting for a report
which would downgrade her school to
inadequate Skies Becky Johnson reports
who can tell me what reading fluency
skill are we looking at today
here at Kate's Grove Primary School in
Reading they're due and ofsted
inspection it's absolutely agonizing
waiting for the call it's stomach
churning the head teacher will only find
out inspectors are coming the day before
Sunday night I don't sleep I start to
get that anxiety that anxious feeling in
my tummy Monday I come to work and every
time the phone rings I jump or if I'm
out of the office or I'm with children
somebody comes to find me I instantly
think I've said we're just on ten tokes
all of the time it's the kind of
pressure head teachers say Ruth Perry
was under she killed herself after her
school was downgraded prompting calls to
pause inspections but ofsted say that
won't happen as they don't believe it
would be in children's best interests
head teachers say they're not opposed to
inspections but they want the system
reformed they say the current system
leads to a single high-stakes judgment
where after just two days of inspection
schools are labeled either outstanding
good requires Improvement or inadequate
data shows almost three quarters of
schools in England were rated good after
their most recent inspection with just
12 given the two lowest ratings
but teachers say the top marks are
becoming increasingly difficult to
achieve and don't think it's fair the
entire performance of a school is
reduced to a single word ofsted argue
the current system is simple and
accessible if the grades are replaced
and the overall effectiveness grade is
replaced as is being suggested then what
replaces it has to give parents a good
idea of the sort of place they want to
send their children but had teachers say
something has to change your entire
School judgment for the next five years
on a piece of paper can can be reliant
on that one thing Sophie Greenway worked
with Ruth Perry for years and is
devastated for her family they've lost
their mum
plus their wife
and I love speaking out now can't bring
her back but she has to
not have died for no reason she feels
the must be a better way of assessing
schools Becky Johnson Sky News reading
shares in Germany's biggest bank fell by
more than eight and a half percent today
is concerns over the health of the
global financial sector continue the
fall in Deutsche bank's value followed
the collapse of two banks in the U.S and
the rushed takeover of Swiss giant
credit Swiss by its rival UBS last
weekend
the Prime Minister has expressed concern
over growing tensions in the West Bank
following a meeting with his Israeli
counterpart in Downing Street shouts
from protesters could be heard as Wishy
sunak and Benjamin Netanyahu shook hands
[Music]
and Plymouth city council has lost its
high court bid to overturn an injunction
Banning it from felling trees on a site
in the city center the injunction was
brought by campaigners after 110 trees
were chopped down as part of a
regeneration project in the city center
the leader of Plymouth city council has
said he will step down over the
controversy
now over the past few days millions of
us will have had our annual council tax
bills land on the doormat and for most
it will mean higher payments for the new
year councils though are finding it hard
to fund the full range of services with
62 pence in every pound now spent on
social care Tom Cheshire from our data
and forensics team has been looking at
the funding figures and the impact cuts
are having on local communities so this
this happened just last night yes uh
about 10 o'clock last night a local
resident put on Facebook Continental
News and Views about how disgusting and
disgraceful this flight is the fabric of
our society is made up of many threads
along with it seems carpets and laundry
baskets fly tipping here in congleton
East Cheshire is a very small strand
but tug at those threads year after year
and it adds up to the sense that the
social fabric the deal between citizens
and state is freeing well obviously as
you can see here we've got beautiful
countryside and it's a real eyesore so
as well as the financial cost of
clinging it all up we are seeing our
area being blinded tempers are freeing
too this driver stopped next to us to
complain
[Applause]
well it's other problems like potholes
this road is on a school route and has
been like this for five years
and Sky News analysis of council
spending confirms that sense of decline
in the everyday activities of councils
spending on roads has dropped from
nearly a billion pounds across all
councils 10 years ago to around 700
million pounds today street lights have
lost a hundred million pounds in funding
and that's because councils are spending
more money on social care which they
have a legal duty to provide unlike
roads and Street lighting it's gone from
26 billion pounds 10 years ago to 30
billion pounds today even after
adjusting for inflation
Jaguar games Cheshire East Council
spends 64 and a half percent of its
Budget on social Care on places like
this and on people like David Ryder
there you go
David's 57 years old lives in full-time
care in congleton and is a massive fan
of 80s New Wave Music
[Music]
the highlight of his month is a disco
for disabled people run by volunteers
other community activities have been cut
by the council do you feel like there's
less services from the government to
help you it's about the government did
politics weight in mental health and
also physical health
um yeah I think even previous to you
being with us there was a lot more
things funded for you to do wasn't there
yeah yeah and I think we've definitely
seen that cut back
Cheshire East Council told us it was
facing unprecedented Financial pressure
like councils across the country demand
for social care is rising so Cuts have
to be made elsewhere
pulling at those threads yet again
Tom Cheshire Sky News concordon East
Cheshire
now one of Britain's Finest actors is
about to sign off in one of the world's
finest TV shows Brian Cox plays the
foul-mouthed billionaire father from a
family of media magnets in the
multi-award winning series succession
far from his screen role he told us he's
a socialist and the show is about the
horrific wealth Gap as our arts and
entertainment correspondent Katie
Spencer reports
[Music]
if anyone could intimidate the stock
markets into shape arguably it's TV's
Logan Roy a succession's leading man
Brian Cox says goodbye to the
megalomaniac millionaire media Mogul we
love to hate he's on the floor at a time
explaining what he's doing he's amazing
terrifyingly nosy it's like if Santa
Claus was a hitman
all the backstabbing and double dealing
of the way Star Family Empire is about
to climax in the fourth and final series
The perhaps ultimate social commentary
on capitalism so I think we really need
to think rethink our politics and our
politics is in deep
really and there's been to be seen to be
in deep for the last 12 years that's the
point of doing the show it's a great
social satire it's about the horrific
wealth Gap we don't see very many poor
people in succession they're ignored and
it's and it's a question that you should
ask yourself why are they ignored
because those people are not interested
in what's going on on the lower strata
of life
politics truly close to the Scottish
actor is that of the SNP the departure
of first Minister Nicholas sturgeon on
his mind at the moment we mustn't give
up the
the pursuit of Independence we can't
separate ourselves off we are part of
these British Isles but we should no
longer be a United Kingdom we should be
a United Federation we should be
separate autonomous States one thing
that has United Cox with succession fans
is an apparent appreciation for Logan
Roy's sweary slams they come up and they
say can can I take a photo of you
telling me
and you go now that's the easiest thing
in the world for me to say because I
really do want
brace yourself for the finale of
arguably the finest television show of
the decade and the big reveal of who's
finally left standing at the end Katie
Spencer Sky News
can't wait to watch that my money's on
cousin Greg and that was Sky News at 10
coming up we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's papers in press preview
including this story it's on the front
of the telegraph which says the UK reset
with the EU is in disarray as the king's
visit to France is canceled and tonight
I'll be joined by Rachel canliff who is
senior associate editor at the new
Statesman and former conservative
special advisor Anita botan speaking to
them in a couple of minutes to join us
[Music]
thank you